So here's the answer. We had to make two changes. The first was defining a new
class and we defined a class called about, it provides a get method and all it's
get method does is return the strain, this my udacious project. We also had to
change the way we construct the web application and we added a new tuple. Here
the regular expression 'dMatches just one string, the string slash about and
it's associated with that about class and will call the get method when there's
a request to get about. The rest is the same, if this doesn't match, we'll try
to match this next pattern which will match any other request and use lucky
search. Note that the order of these things does matter. If we had them in
reverse order, we'd never see the about page, because about would still match
this regular expression, and would use the lucky search get method before
getting to about. That's why we need you to have about first.